can start with with the operation
on the ground in kabul at the moment can
you just give us the latest on operation
pitting the the numbers evacuated and
quite how close we might come to just
getting everyone out of the country
well we're not going to get everyone out
of the country i've been consistent uh
throughout the last few weeks on that
the good news however is that we have
evacuated over 2 000 people in the last
24 hours
uh that's another sort of 700 extra than
we did last 24 hours
it means we evacuated eight thousand six
hundred people since
uh the beginning of this in august the
fourteen said indeed
over ten thousand so we've broken the
ten thousand barrier since april of all
the arab british nationals and other
entitled personnel to come out the
country that is a significant piece of
work
uh we have our flow
of aircraft uh steady we have
availability
and the challenge is really getting
people to the airport
to the processing center and then taking
on to the plane but so that the key
thing is the flow of people
into the airport and some of that is not
within our control that's getting
through taliban checkpoints
that is the journey
from kabul to the airport and then
finally when they get there
uh there's about for example 3 000
people outside the british uh uh
controlled gate or the british u.s
control gate
where we need to have a flow that's
constant to allow people in
and there's some nearly 15 000 people
around the whole airport so all of that
is the big challenge
just in terms of the of the security
situation uh are in and around campbell
there but of course we have seen our
armed forces performing their
humanitarian duties but they are there
in a security capacity as well
just how much of a threat do we think
there is in and around the airport at
the moment particularly perhaps
from terrorist attack al qaeda islamic
state or or other kind of groups that
may well be affiliated or arriving in
country and afghanistan
well
certainly as we get closer to the
deadline of the 31st of august which i
you know i know at the g7 there will no
doubt be a discussion about whether that
is possible to move but the taliban were
pretty clear yesterday
uh that as we get closer to the deadline
i think this it it's correct to say that
the security risk goes up it just gets
more and more dangerous as sort of
add-on groups and other terrorist groups
such as isis would like to to be seen to
take greater credit or like to be seen
uh to chase the west at the airport that
is inevitably going to feed their
narrative and their ambitions uh the
taliban actually are controlling the
outer ring uh off the airport and indeed
checkpoints for kabul that makes it
harder for isis terrorists and the
taliban and isis have no friendly
relationship at all but yeah we are very
mindful that we're very very
uh vulnerable should uh these terrorists
choose to do something and that's why
the bravery of our soldiers and indeed
you know of of many of those people from
other nations doing that job is is
amazing they are literally
out there amongst uh very very desperate
people
and the situation could get more
insecure so that's why we're trying
everything we can to prioritize people
and get them through
how quickly could we get out of the
country if if we needed to do so i know
from conversations i've had with a
couple of people who are on the ground
in kabul that
there are real concerns about the
prospect of perhaps even a suicide
bomber coming close to the garden
well we have lots of methods you could
obviously
seal the gates you could obviously
put yourself behind barriers that would
make it even harder to process
members of the arab scheme or indeed
other entitled personnel and that's a
very
difficult uh choice that that our men
and women of armed forces have to make
literally every minute which is where do
i put myself in order to help this
humanitarian crisis so um
there are obviously steps you can do
there's also the issue of you know of
course we could leave uh in a hurry if
we had to but of course that the
trade-off there is how much equipment do
we leave behind
how many more people do we leave behind
and that's why we are working every
minute to try and go to the very last
minute and to take both people out and
then take our own personality
indeed and and of course the question
becomes just when that that last minute
may be we understand of course that the
prime minister and
other allies that around the g7 table
will be attempting to lobby the u.s
president today to perhaps push past the
31st of august but you know given that
which we heard from skye's interview
with the taliban yesterday about it
being a red line it seems pretty
unlikely that there will be any shift
i i think it is unlikely um
not only because what the taliban has
said but also if you look at the public
statements of president biden
i think it is an unlikely it is
definitely worth us all trying and we
will
and we've also changed internally within
our own military system uh how quickly
it could take for us to get out because
for every hour we can squash the
military evacuation is an hour we can
add on to help the civilian evacuation
and that and that's that is those are
the tough choices that myself and
admiral ben keys the chief
commander of the whole operations of
joint operations have to take which is
you know equipment people
uh afghans uh and you know making sure
all of that is done wrapped around safe
and secure security for the people on
the ground
um reports this this morning minister
indeed i believe mps were briefed on it
yesterday
that we have collected people from
afghanistan that were on
the no-fly list can you just tell us a
little bit more about that there seems
to be some confusion one person was on a
no-fly list
made it to the united kingdom but the
assessment at this end was that they
they didn't pose a security risk
well yes so two things
people sort of wonder why we don't just
effectively open the gates in kabul and
let everyone on on a flight and one of
the reasons is that we securely uh
screen them we you know we take their
identity we check against our databases
and we do our very best to minimize
any risk to the united kingdom should
those people come back but of course
those the proportion of people that crop
up on that is absolutely tiny
and then they usually get extra checks
or indeed in some cases they get
rejected and you know i've i have read
in the media some cases of people who
are rejected
and i can't publicly say why but i know
that they were not rejected for the
reasons they often give the media and so
we have to do that and that is you know
quite rightly that's what we have to be
held to account for um i mean i think
what you can say about this particular
case and i don't know the details of the
individual but what i can say having
been the security minister is two things
one is uh that it worked i mean the
watch the watch list or the no-fly list
pinged and the individual was identified
so that that is a plus sign that it
worked
and that despite the fact they came
through unconventional routes
effectively you know from afghanistan on
the military flight onto the uae and
then back to the uk uh the system kept a
time of them and i think that that is
that that's something that other
countries very often don't have so
that's a plus the second thing is and i
can't give you too much detail because
of operational security but
we call it generically the no-fly list
but it it has many sub-divisions i mean
it could be this individual and this is
speculation about this particular
individual but it could be it's no fly
until they're checked it could be
uh you know the lots of different
conditions before they fly it's not
necessarily you are that dangerous you
can't come on airplane it may be just
check who they're flying with uh before
they get on a plane so i can't speculate
on this particular uh individual but but
i think that's why you saw the home
office statement saying on further
examination the individual himself uh i
think was um
able to proceed so i don't think i would
take the same alarm and i i'm saying i
wouldn't i wouldn't
you know i wouldn't pretend otherwise
having done three years of security
minister plus watched on a daily basis
often reports about people whether
they're pinged or not i wouldn't be as
alarmed as some of the media headlines
are about this individual and i would
also
take some comfort that this process is
working and flagging people
um minister i wonder if we can turn our
attention to a story that appears to
have emerged over the past few hours
regarding the former royal marine
pen farthing he of course operating at
an animal charity in uh in afghanistan
he claims having raised half a million
pounds to to repatriate himself staff
and animals that that flight has been
blocked by by the ministry of defense
what's the truth in all of this
well so first of all i i've listened to
this and look
penn farthing is a british possible
holder and has done an amazing thing in
kabul he was offered
a flight out i think last friday or
certainly he was called forward to the
airport for processing his own wife i
think left
about the same time
and exited the country and that is our
strong advice to him is to
leave the country
no one is blocking
the charter flight that people have
raised money
other than the fact it this is not about
flights on the ground
and whether or not
penn can get on the flight this is
simply not about you know if that
aircraft flew in today it would probably
sit there it would block the airfield it
would sit there empty because it's about
getting as i said earlier the flow
through
the gate through the barriers and into
uh the airport and onto the aircraft it
there's a confusion and i i think i'm
afraid some of the campaigners have
you know latched on to the fact they've
charted a plane as this somehow is the
magic wand the magic wand is where the
people can get through kabul through the
taliban checkpoint
and then through the 3000 plus people
waiting
some of whom are waiting in front of the
queue because they are under real threat
direct threat
right now from taliban children families
we've seen it on your own amazing
reporting i watched your reporters
report first thing this morning
and you know i am not prepared to
prioritize for example pets over people
i i want people to come through that
flow so this is not about whether you've
got a chartered aircraft it's not about
that capacity i just got off the phone
from admiral benkia a joint commander of
the whole operation this is simply about
could he get through the gates or could
his people get through the gates now he
could get through the gates the british
passport holder he was called forward on
friday and i recommend he takes that
his workforce have been offered
as entitled personnel uh places and they
will be able to be called forward but i
cannot guarantee that in this window
they will be processed onto aircraft all
i can say is that they qualify
and i as i've said not everyone will get
through
as for the animals that he is rescued
and saved it is just not going to be the
case that i will prioritize them
over the men women and children that we
see in desperate need at the gate you
know i regret that but i don't believe
that uh you know that the taliban's main
point of target will be his workforce
and indeed his
his the the pets and the animals he is
looking after compared to some of those
other people desperate in front of the
queue
sure but minister the the argument that
is made by mr farthing is that this
operation this airlift was okayed by
downing street was okayed by the prime
minister is that just not the case then
no i i i i i
first of all um i i'm not sure penn
farthing has been well advised by his uk
based advisor donnick dyer who i saw a
rant on twitter from him and he has been
incredibly abusive to a range of people
including
my advisor first of all my advisor does
not make decisions on who comes in and
out of airports
that is totally misleading to suggest he
could block anything
i make decisions as does admiral ben key
and my senior military advisor leaders
as does the foreign office who manage
the entitled personnel list
so that is just misleading and totally
wrong and i think if pen pen understands
that then maybe he won't be making some
of the things that i've heard him say uh
today
no one has blocked the plane other than
the fact it is not about a plane flying
in an aircraft
in the middle of a military evacuation
one of the biggest military evacuations
of all time is not
a uh going to help the situation and b
is not the issue if there were places on
our plane
and they could get through
the queues and they could be processing
time and that's the key could they get
through the gate
is not about the plane then of course
they will be on those flights he has
been told that his people and him are
eligible to resettle in the uk as a
british passport holder so is he but but
frankly my day job and my evening job
and my night job is focusing on those
thousands of people outside the front
gate he's been offered a place last
friday he was called forward i strongly
recommend he does that
and you know once the evacuation is over
i genuinely believe that his workforce
and if he wants to repatriate the pets
that he looks after and the the strays
i genuinely believe that they will be
allowed to move forward
after you know at a later date when that
airport opens but you know frankly i
have to prioritize people at the moment
over pets